there's more to sight than just being
able to see the crowd you can definitely
feel
the atmosphere
there's a vibe in the air there's the
energy in the air there's the sound
it's amazing to hear the fans
especially when we run out of tunnel
i'm jake wilson i'm the long snapper of
the university of southern california
trojans i'm completely blind i have no
eyes
i went into playing football with the
mentality that i had nothing to lose
long stopping is an art
you definitely have the mechanics but a
lot of it's just feel feeling that ball
coming off your fingertips in a spiral
how hard you're throwing it you know
where you're releasing it just kind of
getting that velocity and that and the
accuracy
life's unfair football is unfair but at
the same time
it's up to you of how far
you want to take yourself
when i was eight months old i was
diagnosed with a rare form of eye cancer
called retinoblastoma
when the doctors found my cancer
it was completely taken over my left eye
so they almost immediately removed my
left eye
from there on you know just a cycle of
you know the cancer coming back then we
fight it with treatments
doctors finally said listen we pretty
much exhausted all all treatment options
the safer option is just you know the
removal of the eye
growing up in the 2000s where coach
carroll was so dominant with usc it was
hard not to be a usc fan
i always loved football i continued to
play flag football my eighth grade year
after losing my sight it was not
anything close to tackle football
as i entered high school i decided not
to play football for my freshman and
sophomore year it really was something i
didn't think i could do but eventually
my love for the game really overcame any
doubts and i learned how to be an asset
i just love the camaraderie of football
i love being part of the team love
putting on you know just the pads and
the jersey and stuff and
being part of the team was enough just
to get me to try
are two of the ten refugees selected to
be a part of the first olympic refugee
team
they will be competing in judo
they both fled conflict in the
democratic republic of congo and in the
2016 olympics will compete without
both sought asylum in brazil during the
judo world championships in 2013.
they haven't seen their family since
the family
by competing in the olympics they are
bringing their
so
i broke my neck
i beat cancer and i'm going to rio
this is the first time that women's
rugby will be in the olympics i'm
jillian putter and i play rugby for teen
usa
rugby in particular is a very good life
lessons teacher so when you get tackled
you have to get back up no matter how
hard it is i'm going to get up
i broke my neck playing rugby in 2010.
but when i was hit
i felt and i heard just pop pop pop pop
and i knew immediately something was
wrong
when the doctors came in and told me i
might not ever be able to play rugby
again i like tried to silently cry for a
while
i went through this like period of
allowing myself to to be upset and then
being like get it together jillian like
you can be strong in this moment there
was about a year between when i broke my
neck and when i was able to get back on
the field with my team
and then in june of 2014 i was diagnosed
with a very rare soft tissue cancer i
had chemo and radiation for seven months
and i lost about 20 pounds
throughout the treatment i was actually
able to work out and that was something
that i was pretty adamant about
thankfully the chemotherapy worked and
i'm cancer-free but it could have easily
turned the other way and i don't think
i could even imagine what that would be
like but i would hope that i would still
have that attitude of never giving up
and rugby was
instrumental in getting me back to where
i am today the rugby community it really
helped me
stay positive and keep working out keep
that fire to say i'm gonna be back
and i'm gonna be ready for real
i can pinch first 445 pounds
i could flip a 270 pound tire
i can do handstand push-ups
and i can climb a rope
i can look damn good doing it
i'm zach rule an adaptive crossfitter
and a power lifter i was born with a
deformity and pretty much my legs look
real messed up so i would never be able
to walk
using them so they made a decision to
get them amputated i've been an amputee
double amputee since i was two years old
my relationship with fitness
started out in high school i just
started lifting weights like anybody
else and i always always did it for
appearance at first
if i'm just going to be a torso i'm
going to be one damn looking good torso
and then it just took over my life like
i wanted to know everything there is to
know about the anatomy of the human body
how to get stronger what creates muscle
growth like i was a sponge
i've been told i can't bench press more
than 400 pounds my ass i've been told i
wouldn't have a gym my own
my biggest motivation in life is people
tell me i can't do something
i offer free classes or free personal
training to adaptive athletes or people
with disabilities so i have a girl with
cereal palsy
i have a girl that has a spinal cord
injury and i have another quadruple
amputee that i'm personal training right
now
crossfit has done so much for my life
and i feel like i just want to pass that
on and show everybody that it is
possible you can work past disabilities
and wherever your goals are especially
fitness wise you can meet them it's just
gonna be a little bit different route
than somebody else
not done
song
a
foreign
you